[موسيقى]
من الصعب أن تفوتك إزمير وإفيسوس ، ولكن على
مسافة بسيطة ، هناك بلدة حققت
نجاحًا كبيرًا مع
الزائرين ، حيث يتدفق السائحون الأتراك
[موسيقى]
هنا للحصول
على ملاذ مثالي
وباقينا يكتشفون ذلك للتو
جوهرة خفية
[موسيقى]
الشمس الساطعة والهواء المنعش والأشخاص الذين
يزورون من كل مكان لحضور مهرجان الأعشاب المحلي
[موسيقى
] لست متأكدًا من سبب ارتدائي لهذا الطوق أو لماذا أرتدي
هذا الطوق
جيدًا
[موسيقى]
ولكن عندما يكون بارهان في روما
يعرف كل زاوية
وركني وسيريني حول
هذا ما نسميه لا بادا ولكن في
اللغة اللاتينية يمكننا تحميصه
يمكننا طهيه يمكننا غليه ،
فهي مفتوحة تمامًا هنا يريدون
السياح والمزيد منهم هذا هو
أغلى
ما نسميه shave kitty boston ،
ماذا تفعل به ،
يمكنك تحميصه ، إنه جيد جدًا
لكليتك والبروستاتا ، بالإضافة إلى أنه يقول
جيدًا ربما لا ينبغي أن ننظر
إليه بهذه الطريقة ربما
و  آه بذور عرق السوس
نعم يمكنك أكل ذ  أنت متأكد من
أنه يمكنك أكله ، فهو لا يستقبلني ،
ولا أعرف في
جميع أنحاء تركيا ،
أوه ،
هذا حلو ، نعم حبيبتي ،
لم أكن لأفكر أبدًا في الاستمتاع
بمص الليمون ،
واستمتع به ،
الجميع هنا حريص على الإشارة إلى
جمال هذا المكان
[موسيقى] التي
تبعد بضع ساعات بالسيارة عن الكهرباء
هي البرك الحرارية السماوية التي
يترجم اسمها حرفياً باللغة الإنجليزية
إلى قلعة القطن
لأنه يمكن أن يُفهم خطأ أنها
غيوم ملائكية إذا كنت تنظر إلى الزاوية الصحيحة
[موسيقى]
فهي  مشهد من الحجر الجيري القديم
الذي توافد عليه السياح لعدة
قرون
هناك نذهب
وأعتقد أنني سأغمس أصابع قدمي ، هل هذا الماء
دافئ ،
إنه زلق للغاية على الرغم من
أنه زلق للغاية ، فقد تمت كتابة كارثة في
كل مكان ، هذا أفضل أوه
نعم
إنه ممتع هذا  إنها حقًا ممتعة
وبسيطة
[موسيقى]